[Music]
I don't like to be an observer looking
distantly at something I want it to
engage me and take me
there it's not simply the place the
furniture the Wardrobe with the streets
look like like and all that detail which
is terribly important but it's also
period accurate attitude psychology the
absence of psychology he is very
interested in internal life internal
life is 90% of all of his notes doing a
deep dive and trying to recreate a
cultural reality and a psychological
reality excuse me please my husband
isn't here he's
sing what's a stereotypical marriage in
Bourgeois Regional provincial mod 1957
what's the authority structure because
Enzo is a reverent he disputes Authority
and makes his own way EV is looking for
a scapegoat then here I am that's
different than somebody exercising Free
Will where there's no Authority
structure and they don't have something
to push against when we lose you're a
Lynch it's enough to make the pope weep
it's the value system it's all those
things and that's not work that's the
adventure of it and I can't imagine any
reason to do it any other way you
generated all of these
unresolved things you don't how
now Michael is not only paying attention
to our performances he's paying
attention to the way the light is moving
in every single take the way the camera
operator is conducting his business and
there's so many different elements at
play get some people walk through I
don't see anybody saw too static he's a
conductor he's waiting for like that
perfect perfect Symphony to come come
together his focus is I think
challenging for a lot of people let's go
because you have to just be with him and
just go on the ride and just expect the
unexpected and be ready to go with
it and I think that's a good artists is
they take what's happening in front of
them very much like what's going on in
the car on the track and you adapt and
you make it work for
you let's get that camera in make for me
director photography is is a casting
process I think we should try and get
the over at the same time I wanted a
particular kind of active lighting
that's apparent in caravaggio's
paintings where the light seems to enter
very dramatically and it's almost as if
accidentally the light is hitting a part
of a leg a hand slice of light hits a
[Music]
face Michael's command of the frame his
use of the frame is such a signature of
his and it's specifically tied to what's
happening dramatically in the scene
between the
characters thank you the dramatic scenes
have a certain stateliness and
uniformity within the color and the
camera movements and then opposed to
that every time there's a race car and
the race cars are red vibrant
Savage we get in the cars the camera is
handheld and it's in the passenger seat
next to the driver and you feel the road
noise and you feel the dust on your
face you could easily have made this a
movie that's just cars moving
fast but I never feel like in Michael's
movie see sacrifice his character for
any kind of spectacle ready and R face
Michael gives his actors space and is
intelligent enough to not control that
there was a shorthand there's that
respect when to give them something that
will open them up or when to kind of you
know be invisible he's there holding
your hand through that process he's
thought of every
angle we all know it's our deadly
passion our terrible Joy a millimeter
will change everything for him that's
good that's but not to say that he
doesn't have his own sense of
improvisation himself he still is making
up shots and following impulses he is
like nonstop for like 16 hours a day and
I know that when he goes home he keeps
writing or editing and he a machine and
cut No
Deal